if you miss part one of this little
miniseries about my personal YouTube
rules you can click right there to watch
it isn't that magical it's like you can
reach inside of this video and watch a
different video no ok these ones are
going to be a little bit more quickfire
because yesterday I only managed to get
through three whereas today I have five
possibly six I don't know I keep on
thinking of new ones so let's go number
four I don't like to overuse annotations
in fact if I can avoid it
I try not to use them at pool a lot of
these rules just come off the back of me
being the kind of person who watches a
lot of YouTube videos and I personally
find that if I'm being inundated with
little colorful boxes everywhere it's
just really annoying I don't like being
distracted by that kind of stuff and I
wouldn't want to distract you with that
stuff either because you know I've made
a thing that I'm proud of that I want to
share with you and I'd like you to watch
that thing instead of all of the things
around here numero five oh my try to
make sure that the thumbnail and the
title of a video are going to be a good
representation of what that video is
actually going to be my preference is
not to do what I can to get people to
click on a video that I've made its to
get people to actually watch a video
that I've made and so I find it kind of
illogical when I click on a video
thinking that it's one thing and then
turns out to be something else because
what happens at that point I just don't
watch the video do I if your primary
goal on YouTube is just to get as many
hits as you possibly can then sure that
is the way to do that it will probably
work but I just prefer the idea of
having actual real people watching my
content as opposed to just having the
biggest number possible sex that's fix
in German by the way not the other thing
if I'm offered any kind of business
opportunity then I'm only going to take
it if it's actually gonna make my videos
better I feel very fortunate that I'm in
a position where I have people watching
me here on the Internet and with that I
wouldn't ever want to try and take
advantage of your attention by making a
bunch of money trying to sell you
something that you probably don't want
the kind of opportunities that I try to
take if I'm fortunate enough to get any
on a the ones that resolve me being able
to make a video that I would not be able
to make otherwise and be the ones that
offer me cool experiences as opposed to
money I feel like if someone's gonna
offer me money to talk about a thing
then that's just gonna add the wrong
kind of bias to my opinion of that thing
my preference is just to give you the
most honest and real opinions that I can
about things that I do or don't like and
money just doesn't fit well with that
idea this wall is actually one that I've
deliberately saved to last because as a
result of doing this midlife crisis
YouTube project thingy
my opinions of it are sort of shifting a
little bit the rule that I wrote down is
to never ever have any kind of schedule
ever but I think a better way to put
that rule is to say only have a schedule
if that schedule is actually going to
help the videos that you're making as
opposed to hindrance one of the things
that the company YouTube themselves
suggest to people making videos is to
have a strict schedule and upload you
know one video every Friday and one
video every Monday or whatever but
personally I've always found that in the
past if I've tried to stick to any kind
of schedule then it just piles on the
pressure and if anything just makes me
feel less creative but I do now think
that having the right kind of schedule
for example can also help to encourage
creativity as well I guess if you're
gonna have a schedule make sure you're
doing it for your own benefit as opposed
to the assumed benefit of getting more
hits or whatever when it comes to all of
these rules the main thing about them
really is that they are all specifically
tailored for me so I wouldn't want
anyone to just automatically take all of
these things and just say that's the way
I'm gonna do it too because different
things work for different people so if
you don't agree with anything that I've
said in these videos then just do the
opposite because if that is what feels
right for you that it is also probably
what will work for you the end you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool I was too much tea
in one go